what's the sexiest most beautiful idea
or concept to you about snapdragon start
there the way i would describe it and i
think the reason we have been uh
successful with it
is to really understand
uh how how to build a platform a single
chip like a single chip
that will have every single capability
if you want to make this
smartphone in the palm of your hand
you know
something that has all of your computing
needs and it was the ability to get from
an engineering standpoint
ability to get into a single chip
of not only
all possible connectivity technology
from cell alert wi-fi to bluetooth to
every single constellation
of satellite for position location but
at the same time you know a very power
efficient uh you know single thread and
multithreaded cpu
a gpu for your
all of your graphic demands gaming
fastest growing segment for gaming
is uh mobile gaming
an artificial intelligence processor
which we call the neural processor unit
and then a video engine uh and a
multimedia engine for every single
application audio
everything so it's a single chip
that has every single computing
technology you need in the phone and
what's exciting about it
is what we already knew for example when
you think about camera or computer
vision
you see that advancements in the
technology now
happens in
the smartphone first versus traditional
camera so the beauty about the
snapdragon is we always have this thing
with within qualcomm
the phone
it's small you have to be able to hold
it you're gonna touch your face so you
cannot be hot
uh you have to manage thermals
you expect
to have a full day of battery life but
then you wanted to not be
sending data into uh 10 or 100 megabits
you want gigabits you wanted to be able
to have
eight core processors you want to have a
gpu with ray tracing you want to have
all of those things that you can only
get
into
sometimes a desktop pc
and to do all of that in your phone and
be able to be
in the leadership position generation
after generation is an incredible thing
and we're very proud of that at qualcomm
yeah so you have to do the wi-fi 5g all
the and you have to be good at everyone
all of those technologies pack it all in
and
there's also pressure to make the thing
faster and faster and faster and then
there's more and more applications
you're supposed to be effortlessly
using and then you mentioned the npu gpu
cpu they have to also dance together
somehow either to communicate well share
memory or not depending on what the
application is and your battery has to
last all day
so think about that from a company like
qualcomm we have to be good and each and
every one of those technologies we can
just say oh we're a cpu company or a gpu
company or we're ai company we have to
do everything
you